hey dr. Berg here we have one of my
friendly patients right here so she's
came from Connecticut for a few days and
just kind of like a little snapshot of
your situation like kind of where your
work and the stress that you go through
you kind of had some some
flight-or-fight going on right a lot of
fight or flight going on yes yes
constant constant fight-or-flight could
not take any more stress could not
tolerate anybody everybody annoyed me
everything and everybody including my
dog annoyed me so yeah I'm in
fight-or-flight work in the prison
system a psychotherapist so a little bit
of stress oh yeah just a little vada um
so yeah but um I'm very much addicted to
coffee yeah so huh how much coffee maybe
would you have in a given day well like
I told my regular physician when she
asked how much coffee I drink and I said
three to four and she thought I meant
three to four cups but I'm three or four
pots of coffee and so I came to dr.
Berg's office yesterday today is my
second day and I had one cup cup of
coffee this morning and I don't even
need any more right now I am so
energized but not from coffee right
right no is it did you normally do some
sleeping issues
occasionally right big time sleeping
issues um either couldn't get to sleep
or couldn't stay asleep um usually I'd
be going to falling falling asleep at
2:30 3 o'clock in the morning I would
sleep little cat naps throughout the day
and then six o'clock pretty much give up
when I heard the birds so so so the
flight or flight mechanism it's
something in the and adrenals that key
stays wired all the time and that's why
the car I mean there's so burnt-out that
you needed coffee to kind of stay awake
but you can't sleep to rejuvenate so you
need the coffee to wake you up so I know
it wasn't perfect but last night how did
you sleep after the first day of work
and I uh amazing I crashed at ten
o'clock ten o'clock
I fell asleep which is ridiculous my
woke up at 3:00 for about five minutes
and got
right just tossed over turn the other
side felt right back to sleep and then
at six o'clock this morning so now from
ten o'clock till six o'clock is eight
hours eight hours of sleep
with the exception of just the waking up
the one time but at 6:00 a.m. I was out
of bed and like I told you this morning
I was ready to clean every room in the
hotel that I'm staying in I was wired in
the shower at 6:00 a.m. I mean it was
just and I've been like that it's four
o'clock and I would have had probably
I'd be in my second and a half pot of
coffee and I had one cup this morning in
a hotel it's amazing it sound like me
and college I did the Cuban coffee by
the pasta tube I have that t-shirt but
the yeah because see when you pull the
stress out and I'm telling you when you
get sleep you can start recharging you
can start feeling better and you don't
really need as much coffee if you're
sleeping but you're just trying to stay
awake no my routine literally was get
out of bed straight in the morning go
straight to the root to the kitchen
start the pot go back to the bathroom
for two minutes go back by then I can at
least get that first cup to get me
enough energy to get in the shower and
then it was just this perpetual you know
then another cup up and I'm talking mug
and I drink the high-octane like I told
you the high-octane so I'm not drinking
cups I'm drinking mugs of coffee then
you take one in the car you know and
then three o'clock four o'clock another
you know mug and I'm drinking it til 10
11 o'clock at night I mean it was it was
just and I know why I was trying to stay
up right but I think I was in that yeah
the flutter fight it hurt her biggest
concern was how she gonna come off the
coffee right was that that was my huge
concern when I spoke to you on the phone
and then when I got down here yesterday
I said dr. Berg I'm really concerned I
want to get off coffee yes I know what
it's doing to me but I was afraid of the
migraines right and um what are we gonna
do with that and so uh I haven't had a
headache I think I just had a little
tenderness up here from the acupressure
which is phenomenal oh my gosh get any
more
you needed that stress reduction there
and then the other thing too is that you
your back has been chronically in pain
for a long time and one of the things
that we do for pain is we always always
always work on the opposite side no one
does that but it really works so we
worked under abdomen and to fix the back
and because if you work on the back
you're going to be on that thing for a
long long time they don't really teach
us that in school but it's something
that just works so that's what we're
going to fix your back by working on the
front part I work on the front yeah yeah
it's been amazing I mean and I just got
just realigned just a little while ago
and I cannot believe where my head is
turning I mean I would just do two here
and here but no popping no and I was
saying after I was aligned at one of my
first acupressure
did he get brighter in here everything
is brighter yeah you know yeah amazing
some of the already one day right now
I'm shocked yeah this is awesome nice
tough to kind of like pull the stress
out get your body calm down so it could
generate energy and really what stress
is it's duck energy so when you release
it it becomes available to you as like
not a nervous energy but like just an
energy that's good yeah well so I told
you you gave me homework yesterday and I
went to the park
this morning before I came here I went
to the park and after my treatment at
four o'clock I'm going back to the park
because that entered I don't I'm jacked
up yeah but I'm not jacked up on coffee
it's its own it must be whatever is
flooding through me and I'm keep looking
two o'clock like okay I should be having
coffee right now I know what's going on
but it's like a memory thing yeah yeah I
have to recondition I guess because I'm
just you know it's a habit that was a
bowl of it for a while no no it happened
yeah so I think the coffee entities
gonna go out of business now and I'm not
gonna be in a row but yeah the energy
level already and I haven't even done
the liver cleanse so when I get home I'm
doing the you know chapter 10 yeah and
then starting the program so I can't
even AM it it gets better than this yeah
it does it'll keep getting up yeah it's
just kind of like if you're tired you're
trying to get energy from something else
whether its food or caffeine or
stimulants but why not just let your
body generate energy it's the source of
the energy or you're the source of the
energy so why depend on something
external so you know
thank you so much thank you so much dr.
Bergin you're welcome as well thank you
thank you